satoru Gojo is the strongest Jujutsu
sorcerer in the world and the man who
could single-handedly destroy Humanity
season 2 of the Jujutsu Kaizen anime is
finally giving us some insight into
Gojo's insane backstory but even with
that information from the anime you
won't get the full truth however by the
end of this video you will know
everything about Gojo's secret past and
hidden power his true intentions and
motivations and why he is actually the
biggest monster in the entire series now
drop a like for goat Joe subscribe for
more Jujutsu Kaizen content and let's
get into it satoru Gojo was born on
December 7th 1989 and he is such a
menace that after his birth the balance
of power in the entire jiu Jutsu World
shifted Gojo was the first person in 400
years to be born with both the power of
Limitless and the power of the six eyes
and this was such a big deal that it
resulted in curses becoming strong
longer after his birth basically the
good guys became so overpowered thanks
to the appearance of Gojo that curses
started getting stronger in order to
compensate I repeat Gojo's birth
literally threw the balance of the
universe out of whack and so the
universe had to start making curses
stronger in order to make up for it if
that doesn't tell you just how
overpowered Gojo truly is then I don't
know what will satoru was so powerful
that the other important sorcerer
families felt intimidated by him and
they were afraid that they would lose
their own status because this one member
of the Gojo family was so freaking
strong these other families went so far
as to put out a hit on him while he was
still a kid but all the bounty hunters
who tried to kill him failed and Gojo
was able to develop into the charismatic
Powerhouse that he is today in fact Gojo
is widely considered to be the strongest
Jujutsu Sorcerer of the modern era and
if you ask Gojo he believes himself to
be the strongest a sorcerer of any era
on several occasions he has stated that
he at full power could defeat even the
legendary sukuna in his prime according
to Gojo's character profile in the first
volume of the manga he can do anything
that he sets out to do essentially
making the impossible possible Gojo is
so strong that if technology ran on
cursed energy rather than gas or
electricity Gojo would apparently have
the ability to power an entire large
Nation like the United States on his own
his powers are so great that they could
pose a threat to the whole world if they
ever ended up in the wrong hands ghetto
has stated in the past that Gojo could
potentially destroy all of humanity so
let's just be glad that he's one of the
good guys now even though the Gojo
family is one of the big three sorcerer
families along with the zenin and Kamal
families satoru is literally the only
known member of the Gojo family in
modern times satoru is the head of the
Gojo Clan and he also seems to be the
only noteworthy sorcerer in the current
generation of the family and yet because
he is so powerful he just kind of solo
carries the entire family and keeps them
at the top of the food chain the Gojo
Clan originally descended from
michizanes sugawara one of the big three
vengeful Spirits from the heian period
of Japanese history he was a true legend
in the Jujutsu world but between him and
satoru there were many other Gojo Clan
Sorcerers in the past so what makes
satoru Gojo in particular so powerful
and why is he so special as a member of
the Gojo bloodline satoru inherited the
prestigious Gojo Clan technique known as
Limitless this cursed technique brings
the concept of infinity into the
physical world allowing its user to
distort and manipulate space in its base
state or neutral state which is known as
Infinity Limitless has the ability to
stop anything and everything including
enemy attacks although technically the
technique doesn't stop things it just
slows them down so much that they may as
well have been effectively stopped let
me try to explain this more clearly by
using the very Paradox that Gojo himself
references when talking about his power
the Paradox of Achilles and the Tortoise
the famed Greek hero Achilles is
challenged to a race by a common
tortoise the slow-moving tortoise says
that it can outrun the great Achilles as
long as it has been given a bit of a
head start Achilles believes himself to
be the fastest man in the world and
there is no way that he could lose to
something as slow as a tortoise so he
accepts The Challenge and the race
begins with the tortoise having a 100
meter Head Start Achilles immediately
rushes forward determined to overtake
the tortoise he quickly covers the
distance of 100 meters and reaches the
point where the tortoise had begun the
race but by that time the tortoise
managed to move 10 meters forward
Achilles then runs another 10 meters to
reach the position where the tortoise
was but by the time he arrives there the
tortoise has moved another meter by the
time that Achilles moved to that
location the tortoise has moved slightly
forward again and so on and so on in the
end Achilles never catches up because
there is always an increasingly small
gap between him and the Tortoise but a
gap nonetheless here's another way to
think about it let's say you want to
walk from One Tree to another in order
to reach the second tree you will need
to reach the halfway point between the
two trees and then the halfway point
between that point and the second tree
and then the halfway point between the
new halfway point and the tree and so on
infinitely if you keep dividing the
remaining distance in half you will
never arrive at your destination and at
some point you will be moving so slowly
that it will look like you're not moving
at all this is a mathematical Paradox
also known as zenos Paradox in
mathematics no matter how many times you
divide a number it will never go down to
zero it will keep going down to smaller
and smaller fractions infinitely but
never to actual zero in the real world
Achilles will easily overtake the
tortoise in the real world if you want
to walk from One Tree to another you
will easily arrive at your destination
of course you won't start infinitely
dividing the distance you cover in half
you're just going to cover the distance
so this is a theoretical mathematical
Paradox not something that occurs in
everyday life however Limitless actually
brings this mathematical Paradox into
reality so if something like an enemy
attack tries to approach the user
Limitless in this case Gojo it will
never reach him Limitless transforms the
finite amount of space between the
attacker and Gojo into Infinite Space
the enemy attack will never make contact
with Gojo because its distance from Gojo
will just keep dividing itself
infinitely the attacker essentially
becomes Achilles and Gojo becomes the
tortoise Limitless is so powerful not
only because it prevents enemy attacks
from making contact with Gojo but also
because Gojo can expand the invisible
infinite barrier that Limitless
generates in order to completely
neutralize enemy techniques and
overpower them outright and if that
wasn't enough there are multiple other
techniques that Limitless allows Gojo to
perform Beyond just Infinity before we
get into the Epic details of these other
overpowered techniques let's quickly
talk about Gojo's other incredible
inherited technique the six eyes the six
eyes is an ocular Jujutsu that's Jujutsu
not Jutsu okay and this ocular Jujutsu
allows its user to detect cursed energy
and see the flow of it as well as to
instantly analyze his opponent's cursed
technique on top of that six eyes allows
its user to have unbelievably precise
control of their cursed energy right
down to an atomic level ensuring that
the user of six eyes will virtually
never run out of cursed energy because
they are able to use it so incredibly
efficiently basically six size allows
Gojo to use so little cursed energy that
he never runs out because he recovers it
faster than he can spend it his supply
of cursed energy is not actually
infinite both Utah and sukuna have more
cursed energy than Gojo overall but
Gojo's efficiency in how he uses it
makes it practically infinite the six
eyes are essentially the perfect
technique for mastering and unlocking
the full potential of Limitless and it
is this unique combination of Limitless
and the six eyes that makes Gojo the
strongest Sorcerer of the modern era the
six eyes is such a rare technique that
no two people can ever possess it at the
same time and as I mentioned earlier
it's been 400 years since a single
person possessed both the six eyes and
Limitless a user of six eyes has visual
Powers Beyond those of any other
sorcerer allowing them to essentially
see in high resolution infrared vision
Gojo can literally see through a
blindfold without a problem and you can
easily see what's happening several
kilometers away in fact the reason why
Gojo uses a blindfold in the first place
is to avoid overly straining his eyes
because the six eyes is a power that is
always on and it cannot be deactivated
in chapter 71 the sorcerer killer toji
fushiguro mentions that he once went to
see the legendary satoru Gojo back when
Gojo was still a kid and Gojo was the
only person who was ever able to detect
toji's presence even while toji was
standing behind him okay now that we've
established what the six eyes power is
let's talk about all the ways that Gojo
combines the six eyes and Limitless in
order to bring out the full potential of
both techniques in absolutely
spectacular ways first let's talk about
blue also known as cursed technique Labs
blue if Infinity is the base form of
Limitless then blue is its strengthened
form and it is activated when Gojo
amplifies the amount of cursed energy
that he is pouring into the technique
blue allows the user to bring more
theoretical mathematical Concepts into
reality this time the concept of of
numbers and negative distance basically
Gojo uses Limitless to create negative
space and then normal space immediately
begins to compensate by drawing
everything towards that negative space
in order to fill it this allows Gojo to
pull people and objects towards that
space at great speed similarly to the
way a huge magnet works this technique
can be used with less intensity in order
to pull in targets towards each other
and this same effect can be used to make
the user himself move at high speeds by
pulling himself so quickly towards a
specific destination then it appears as
if he is teleporting Gojo's ability to
use blue as a means of Transport enables
him to become one of the fastest
Sorcerers in history however the
technique can also be used with more
intensity to pull apart entire buildings
in an instant or to completely destroy
the bodies of enemies blue is a
technique that is very difficult to use
because it requires a lot of cursed
energy and it requires that energy to be
used an extremely precise way luckily
for Gojo the six eyes allows him to do
exactly that next let's talk about red
also known as reversed Limitless red
Gojo uses the positive energy that comes
from his reverse curse technique to
reverse the effect of blue rather than
attracting objects and people like blue
does red repels them if blue is like two
oppositely charged magnets that are
attracted to each other then red is like
two similarly charged magnets that repel
each other Gojo produces a small red orb
on the tip of his finger and when the
power of the orb is released it
generates a massive shock wave that
blows everything within the surrounding
area away from Gojo Red's cursed energy
output is said to be at least twice the
cursed energy output of blue which also
increases the potential for collateral
damage since red requires the use of
reverse curse technique and since it's
only a small number of sorcerers in
history have been able to use this
technique satoru Gojo as one of the only
people to be able to use red in the
history of the world and even he had to
work hard in order to learn how to use
it it actually took a near-death
experience for him to finally figure it
out and if you thought that red and blue
were badass then wait until I tell you
about the super secret Fusion technique
called Hollow technique purple purple is
created through the merging of blue and
red when the two opposite Powers Collide
an imaginary mass is produced and this
Mass has the ability to essentially
erase everything in its path out of
existence purple neither attracts nor
repels it produces a purple energy ball
that simply annihilates everything it
touches the existence of this technique
is such a closely guarded secret that
members of the other prominent families
such as the Zenon Clan don't even know
that it exists and thus they have no
effective way to counter it as it should
be clear by now all of Gojo's powers are
insanely rare and impressive including
the six eyes Limitless itself and the
various techniques derived from
Limitless such as Infinity red blue and
purple but we can't end a discussion on
Gojo's power without talking about his
greatest power of all Gojo's domain
expansion called unlimited void
unlimited void allows Gojo to bring
himself and his Target or targets inside
the Limitless itself as the name
suggests the area within Limitless is an
unlimited void that contains an infinite
amount of knowledge and information in
fact when a Target is forced to enter
unlimited void their mind is immediately
bombarded with endless information to
the point of overwhelming them and
rendering them completely immobile the
user and anyone he touches directly is
immune from this effect but the user's
intended target will eventually lose
their mind and even die if Gojo doesn't
deactivate the power the effect of
unlimited void is so powerful that if a
non-sorcerer is exposed to it for more
than 0.2 seconds they will suffer
lasting consequences and death in those
0.2 seconds an entire six months worth
of information floods into the target's
mind this renders them unconscious and
after they regain Consciousness they
will require like two months of therapy
just to get back to normal although
Gojo's Limitless and its techniques are
amongst the most powerful abilities in
Jujutsu Kaizen and they are quite
possibly the single strongest power when
taken as a whole there are some ways
that exceptionally strong opponents of
Gojo can attempt to counter his
techniques Limitless can be countered by
other exceptionally powerful domain
expansions or domain amplifications and
there are some cursed tools infused with
specialized curse techniques that can
interfere with the power of Limitless
but believe it or not Limitless and the
six eyes are not even the only powers
that Gojo possesses Gojo is extremely
strong and fast physically he has
incredible endurance and he is an expert
in hand-to-hand combat Gojo is also very
tactical and a master strategist and
these important abilities are of course
boosted by the six eyes allowing Gojo to
develop superhuman observational and
analytical skills Gojo is also capable
of producing many other techniques
including black flash curtain simple
domain and falling Blossom emotion
falling Blossom emotion is actually a
secret technique passed down within the
big three sorcerer families that serves
as a countermeasure against the domain
expansions of your opponents this
technique can either nullify domain's
attacks entirely or it can reduce the
damage suffered by the user in case
their opponent's domain is incredibly
strong new Shadow style simple domain
also allows Gojo to counter enemy
domains by neutralizing the can't miss
attacks of the domain in question kojo
doesn't normally need to use this
technique and he only uses it against
the most powerful opponents finally it
is important to note that Gojo's Mastery
of reverse curse technique also sets him
apart from other sorcerers not only can
he use this technique continuously in
order to heal his body in perpetuity but
Gojo can also use reverse curse
technique to recover his burnt out curse
technique after using domain expansion
allowing him to create five or more
domain expansions within the span of
only a few minutes we can't forget that
the vast majority of sorcerers who are
even able to use domain expansion can
only use it like once a day tops so this
is a huge deal and after learning all of
that about Gojo's spectacular powers and
abilities I don't think I need to tell
you how dangerous these Powers could be
if they ever got into the wrong hands if
for whatever reason Gojo turned bad like
his best but ghetto or if he lost
control of his body in some way the
entire world would be absolutely screwed
thankfully despite his ex cities we know
that Gojo is a good guy who wants to
reform the world of jiu Jutsu sorcers
and end the corruption and
discrimination perpetuated by their old
ruling Elite he is determined to Mentor
a new generation of sorcerers who would
go on to change the world for the better
together with Gojo himself that said the
possibility of Gojo one day going
berserk or losing control of his body in
some way is not out of the question and
if this were to ever happen although
Humanity could be wiped out in order to
fully explore the Dark Truth About
Gojo's powers and how they could One Day
end the world as we know it I will have
to get into some spoilers from the
latest arcs of the mangas so with that
said please proceed with caution so far
we've only talked about Gojo's backstory
and powers and not about the current
plot itself but from this point onwards
some important plot points will be
spoiled if you are anime only you have
been warned
during the infamous Shibuya incident
kenjaku and the other villains managed
to seal Gojo inside prison realm a
special grade cursed object that
contains a living barrier constructed
with the final remains of the Buddhist
monk genshin this barrier has the
ability to seal anything or anyone
including Gojo Gojo spends 19 days
sealed inside this object and then he is
successfully unsealed by his allies the
unsealing takes place in chapter 221 of
the manga and this scene in which Gojo
is unsealed tells us a lot about just
how dangerous Gojo could potentially
become while preparing to unseal Gojo
Yuji shoko Hikari Angel and the others
realize that because physical time
doesn't flow in the prison realm there
is no way to tell how Gojo actually
experienced the time he spent sealed
away it might have just felt like a
moment to him or it might have felt like
he was alone for hundreds of years
everyone is is worried about what Gojo's
State of Mind might look like upon his
release and as shoko points out
depending on his mental state it could
actually be dangerous to unseal him in a
confined space so they decide to unseal
Gojo inside an abandoned mine in the
middle of nowhere in order to avoid any
potential destruction to the surrounding
area and even though Gojo is ultimately
fine upon his release and he just rushes
to confront ghetto right away the
preparations that his allies take before
his release confirms the fact that Gojo
has the potential to be extremely
dangerous if Gojo were to ever become
psychologically imbalanced in any way or
if he was to somehow be possessed by
kanjaku or manipulated in some other way
he would become a massive threat not
just to the small community of judicial
Sorcerers but to all of Japan and to the
entire world now Gojo being Gojo not
only did his confinement inside the
prison realm not unnerve him but it
actually made him stronger by teaching
him how to create an extremely small
domain a domain that is so dense and
refined that it's actually smaller than
the size of a basketball this absolutely
insane durability and adaptability is
what we love about Gojo but it is crazy
to think about just how screwed the
entire world would be if Gojo ever
turned to the dark side actually I
wonder if someone who has been as
powerful as Gojo from such a young age
could one day evolve to the point of
surpassing his own Humanity kind of like
Master tangit as powerful and important
as Tangen is to the entire Jiu Jitsu
World Tegan is also potentially
dangerous if tangent evolves too far
beyond Humanity itself there is no
telling what this Godlike creature might
do and how much chaos and destruction
the creature's ultimate power might
cause in some ways the story of tengen
could be foreshadowing the ultimate fate
of Gojo and if that were the case it
would be be a terrifying twist what do
you guys think could Gojo ever become a
threat to humanity if he loses control
of his power or if he is somehow
manipulated into doing evil things by
kanjaku and the villains how strong will
Gojo become by the end of the series and
is he the next tengen could kojo become
a God or a monster don't forget to leave
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you're looking for more epic Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen videos to watch check out
our Jujutsu Kaizen playlist Link in the
description and on screen right now if
you enjoyed this and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch my videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a huge favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing on YouTube is
completely free but it helps me out a
lot